heute haben wieder in München und in
Berlin Mitglieder der sogenannten
letzten Generation wobei man nur hoffen
kann dass das wirklich die letzte
Generation ist sich
illegal Zugang zum Flugfeld verschafft
mit dem Ziel den Flughafen lahm zu legen
und es auch zumindest in München mal
kurz geschafft
ich denke es ist an der Zeit dass wir
diese jungen Straftäter genauso
behandeln die wir jeden anderen
Straftäter auch behandeln würden wir
schauen uns die ganze Zeit schon an was
sie treiben zuerst waren das
Straßenblockaden dann waren das Angriffe
der Sachbeschädigung auf Kunstwerke
jetzt sind das die Flughäfen man fragt
sich was nehmen sie sich als nächstes
vor auf ihrer Homepage steht dass sie
die öffentliche Ordnung stören wollen
ansonsten stört das aber in unserer
Bundesregierung offensichtlich niemanden
weil wir reden immer noch von Aktivisten
und von Klima Retter nein das sind
Straftäter